things are changing a hard time is
coming from mutants they're coming let's
go get them
we need people like you we in front of
the x-men
an urban dungeon now they left something
behind whether you like it or not you're
like your father season why the x-men
shows us
of hiding
change everything everybody I've been
getting a lot of requests to do a gifted
video they're getting ready for their
two-hour finale so I figured the time
was good to do a video because most
people have not been watching week to
week so I'll explain who the big mutants
are which make groups they introduce
like the Hellfire Club and how they're
treating Magneto in the other a-list
x-men characters in what the timeline
the continuity is compared to the movies
be sure to subscribe to get everything
starting with Polaris she's probably the
most interesting character on the show
if you know a little bit about her in
the comics then you know that she's the
illegitimate daughter of magneto there's
a rumor about some terrorist group
you're a part of the Hellfire Club I'm
sorry something funny you
you have no idea do you about your
father
my father is a pilot who died no no
father not the poor sap who married your
mother he must have heard stories I
don't want to talk about it your father
was a member of the Hellfire Club more
than a member a king that makes you
royalty
[Music]
I prefer
magnito the show just confirmed that
they're doing that but she's pregnant
and it sounds like they're combining her
back story in the comics with Scarlet
Witch from the classic Avengers comics
so if you remember what happened to
scarlet witch's children it sounds like
they're gonna do the same thing with her
child because this new idea that they've
introduced on the TV show is the
stacking bonus of mutant abilities when
any two mutants combine their abilities
they get a minor stacking bonus the more
DNA they share the more closely they're
related the bigger the stacking bonus so
Polaris is conducting the traditional
human cloning experiment she's getting
an extra-big stacking bonus so the baby
is making her much more powerful but
here's where we get to the Scarlet Witch
of it all she's diagnosed bipolar on the
TV show and they've hinted that in the
past that she's had mental breaks where
she just goes completely apeshit on
everyone the triplets that we just met
who are part of the Hellfire Club and
the children of Emma Frost are trying to
get Polaris to lose her [ __ ]
so the you got a bunch of people that
are pushing her over the edge
she might wind up miscarrying the baby
and doing a TV show version of the no
more mutants apocalypse just explosion
of power back it up a little bit you're
like wait a minute
children of Emma Frost triplets what's
going on so we learned that they are
triplets they share a hive mind and when
they're in proximity to each other they
also get the stacking bonus making their
psychic abilities that much more
powerful so they're also doing a version
of the Phoenix force which is called the
Fenris force which is also a thing from
the comics but it comes from Baron von
strucker's family so you're like wait a
minute
Baron von Strucker from Avengers age of
Ultron what's going on here think about
Polaris as being Michael Fassbender's
Magneto's daughter so you have Hellfire
Club that happened in the 60s Emma Frost
ends up having triplets much later in
life so all the x-men characters from
the first class movies like the current
generation they're all gone is the TV
shows way of explaining why they can't
do some of those characters so they're
not around live with some big apocalypse
that happen in the past so the really
big characters either die
or mysteriously disappeared but through
the triplets we learned that people are
trying to rebuild the Hellfire Club so
it looks like they're doing a version of
an origin story for Polaris to become
evil more magneto like join the Hellfire
Club and become more of an antagonist
because she's been friends with all
these characters for the entire season
so I think it'll make a little more
sense if she winds up miscarrying her
baby the two Strucker children in
present-day are the great-great
grandchildren of Baron von Strucker when
they combine each other's powers they
have a version of what you would call
the TV shows Phoenix force it's strong
enough to dent adamantium but it is not
nearly as powerful as the Phoenix force
it doesn't work the same it's not like a
cosmic entity with a consciousness of
its own there's still a couple big
reveals left to happen like they haven't
completely revealed the secret of where
the x-men and the Brotherhood of mutants
went so it sounds like they'll explain
that during the finale so if you're
still confused about the timeline this
isn't taking place after Logan even
though that's sort of post-apocalyptic
after this tragedy they kill the rest of
the x-men the mutants aren't around this
isn't doing any of that
think of this taking place in an
alternate reality where everything from
the first class movies had happened so
everything right up till Dark Phoenix
happen then after that for some reason
mutants just mysteriously disappear all
over the place so when you go see Dark
Phoenix later this year that movie takes
place during the 90s that's almost 30
years before the events that are
happening on the show right now so like
when they say she's Magneto's daughter
magneto in present day of this show
would be a very old man he would be like
Ian McKellen's age but he's the Michael
Fassbender version of magneto so for the
most part first class continuity but
there are some differences once you get
to present day so don't tie yourself in
a knot too much trying to connect this
to the movies most of the Easter eggs
for movie related stuff will be stuff
for the movies that have already
happened we'll see what they do with
Dark Phoenix because we haven't even had
a trailer for that yet but I believe
that they haven't wrapped already
they're getting ready to wrap that movie
so we'll probably see the first footage
from that in the next couple of months I
don't know if there's gonna be a Super
Bowl trailer but I'll do a separate
video for what I think the Super Bowl
trailers will be this year be
there are a whole bunch of comic book
movies like I just posted that video
yesterday about every single comic book
movie that's happening this year that
hype trailer so you could just check my
page for that but I almost forgot
talking about Deadpool stuff so I've
been talking about how the purifiers
might show up during Deadpool - the
purifiers actually appeared in this past
episode they reference Reverend Stryker
stuff on the TV show we don't know if
he's going to be part of the Deadpool
movie it's possible because they're
relatively faithful with a few minor
edits when it comes to Deadpool comics
but don't worry about that there'll be
more Deadpool before there is more x-men
movie stuff but just let me know if you
have questions about the series just
post them in the comments below pretty
sure that it's gonna get a season 2 so
it sounds like they're setting up
Hellfire Club to be the villains of the
second season we'll probably find out
about that in the next couple of weeks
they have the tcas so they'll be making
a lot of announcements about all the TV
shows on all the networks so whatever
they end up announcing I'll totally do a
video for it but just leave all your
bonus video requests in the comments
below I've got some new flash to post in
a couple hours and I'm also working on a
black mirror video for the first episode
which is fantastic if you haven't been
watching black mirror season 4 check it
out it's on Netflix they have one of the
greatest Star Trek parodies ever so
while you wait for everything click here
for brand new flash and click here for
brand new black panther thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]